>> TRANSLATOR:, GREISS MAKES TH
HAVE THE PUCK.
>>
CYCLES IT BACK, TOUCH ADD
PALAT, BACK TO  A BIG HIT!
MAROON STSTER VASILEVSKIY DOWNL!
ANOTHER ONE.
BOUNCING PUCK IN
ROSS COLTON, ON A GREAT FEED
THE FOREHAND.
WHAT A BEAUTIFUL PLAY,
BACKWARDS.
RED WINGS SCORE!
REBOUND, RIGHT IN FRONT,
ON THIS OPPORTUNITY, THE SHOT
FROM TOD SCORING
POSITION.
STOOD UP AND KNOCKED OFF THE
PUCK.
>>RED WINGS HAVE TAKEN
RAYMOND, SCORES!
LUCAS RAYMOND OF HOCKEY.
IT LOOKS LIKE COOPER ISIS
THE GOALIE READS THE PUCK AND
HAS TO STAY IN FRONT.
COLTON.
STAMKOS COME OUT IN FRONT.
COLTON, SCORES! COLTON.
HE FINDS A WASCORES!
QUITE THE
THE STIC, WAS THE AMOUNT THEY
RUTTA,  TAKEN BY ZADINA.
AC30 SECONDS.
LITTLE ROOM.
GETS IT BACKCK